I'm here in Grenoble France and surprise
surprises take more bloody day to get
here because the French are on strike is
all of them miserable [ __ ] they may
have done better than was in the World
Cup but we can beat them in the kitchen
I'm here to help a Yorkshire couple who
are letting the side down they think
their food is the best in the world
their wine is the best that cheese is
the best their meat is the best I really
need someone to teach me how to cook so
I can wipe the smile off the faces
hello how are you Vikki Ashanti your
neighbors because I was ill French the
neighbors we've been out his neighbors
for dinner yet however we would not have
the confidence to environment come
around for some drinks but not nothing
cooked they're inviting us to their
house for a meal yes we're too ashamed
to invite them back experience couchez
avec leur no 80 unless you fast food
deficient chips a blonde the potato
potatoes and for me it's not very
elaborate and very often greasy and it
very good what kind of food did you eat
when you went man to their house oh they
had they had wild bar pate that one of
the women had actually gone and caught
the wild bar where the platter it was up
out of this world I don't know how to
cook with the food they have here right
because it's like vegetables they eat
fish cheese and you can't put in a
microwave and gulping the shrine to
England isn't it this is not real you
know this is missing this this isn't
this is I'm very mad none of this stuff
you can get here like beans and sue
wasn't that right so in here we have Mar
beans but me this place is festive with
baked beans yes
do you can't we're going shopping on a
session for kill goo lagoon some attend
a Sunday lunch three of them yet nice on
the vine lovely good no that's not too
scary is it no that's okay he's your
best mate
I feel perfect there's all TMS there you
go and Jenna nice thing about this when
they get to see once a week twice a week
they get to know their kids names they
get to understand you become a bit of a
local then you get the stuff cheaper
yeah I've got to get Vicky to cook a
very simple dish using a cheap cut of
lamb rump we're gonna bone it out roll
it and then tire oh thank you
then this one's on it will see that the
amazing me too we're going to cook the
lamb with couscous and an aubergine
puree
it's the perfect Sunday lunch because
you can make it for a lot of people and
it's very easy to do school the top like
that for me
right so why do we do that and so when
it goes in the marinade it starts to
absorb the marinade look what we do no
just get where the fat is in tonight
marinade okay that doesn't have to be
done for for three or four days you can
honestly be done an hour before you need
it that smells gorgeous
so aubergine opportunity complicated we
had to salt them first I'll soak them
the reason why I have to salt them first
is to get rid of bitterness okay and
then mix your hands through there yeah
definitely good onions straight into the
pan seasoning also with a nice cumin so
have a look at the aubergine now okay
see don't worry about that so much yeah
it's change color / yeah all that water
again little squeeze out there and lon
oh well yeah yeah that's the business
yeah okay / she's into the pan cook the
over jeans with fresh tomato mix them
with onion and cumin and then puree
mm-hmm the laughs okay now remember no
color no flavor
okay now in Japan now they just show
something I don't want to waste their it
goes over the top cuz cuz is the perfect
accompaniment to lamb I'm using half a
bouillon cube which don't worry is
acceptable even in France but with fresh
thyme for added flavor out of store okay
then just add apple sultanas olive oil
and gently heat over Bambury
until it's fluffy yes man
so there's a house yeah cuisine a
bouquet of a city set on you have
changed my idea of English cooking it's
really good Samael agrees on Reza hates
you seated nothing Thank You chef thank
you mrs. lemon zest with the sage and
the parsley strawberryk pork loin with
lemon and sage done